امواج من الطحالب الحمراء على مد الشواطئ
الامريكيه الغربيه وفي عدد من جزر
الكاريبي ظاهره اثارت الهلع بسبب ضخامتها
فقد بينت صور الاقمار الصناعيه ان المد
الاحمر او ما يسمى علميا بسعغسون يصل حجمه
الى مرتين من مساحه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
منذ عشر سنوات هذه هي المره الاولى التي
نرى هذه الظاهره بهذا الحجم تكاثر الطحالب
ادى الى نفوق عدد من الاسماك وحتى بعض
الحيتان وذلك لان هذا النوع يمتص الاكسجين
الموجوده في المياه فيتسبب في اختناق
الاحياء البحريه ولكن العلماء ما زالوا
غير متاكدين من سبب هذه الموجه
يمكننا علاج هذا الامر اذا حددنا سبب
التكاثر وقد تضاعف حجم موجه الطحالب مرتين
بين ديسمبر ويناير يعتقد العلماء ان
الاحتباس الحراري هو من اسباب تضخم حجم
الطحالب التي بتكاثرها تزيد نسبه الملوثات
في مياه البحر التي قد تتبخر لتسقط مع
الامطار لتؤثر بذلك على المحاصيل الزراعيه
وعلى صحه البشر
انسنا الماسي العربيه